per l'italia soltanto per l'italia fra i
paesi più avanzati
la pandemia ha provocato uno scossone
nell'ambito delle abitudini della
comunicazione si tratti della
comunicazione di lavoro della
comunicazione didattica della
comunicazione ludica senza pari perché
il paese è improvvisamente diventato un
paese digitale con l'intera popolazione
improvvisamente riversatasi sul web per
lavorare i smart working per insegnare
ed imparare con la scuola online con la
didattica online e per un utilizzo
ludico del web in termini quantitativi
mai raggiunti prima
soprattutto da un numero così alto di
accessi allora cosa è successo che da un
punto di vista positivo improvvisamente
ci siamo accorti che siamo nel 2020 è
che siamo nell'era del digitale
dell'informazione della comunicazione
digitale di quella che si chiama ai siti
ma che non è mai stata considerata
particolarmente importante centrale
nella vita degli italiani
at large il problema che ci siamo
accorti di essere diventati digitali
senza essere digitalizzati cioè tutti si
sono accorti del pessimo livello delle
con connessioni e del fai da te
generalizzato nel inventare installare
scaricare utilizzare le piattaforme più
diverse in una enorme confusione in cui
le interfaccia ogni volta hanno dovuto
essere ridefinite penso solo alla scuola
perché è stato fondamentalmente il mio
momento più difficile in quanto come
docente universitario se non avessimo
avuto gli alunni ad aiutarci nella
creazione delle piattaforme per fare non
solo le lezioni a distanza ma anche e
vorrei dire con più complicazione ancora
gli esami e le tesi di laurea
io credo che senza gli studenti ci
saremmo trovati in gravissima difficoltà
a causa di un digital divided di
carattere generazionale dunque digitali
ma non digitalizzati perché perché
appunto pur essendo un paese
g8 e del g20 noi non abbiamo autostrade
informatiche non abbiamo infrastrutture
informatiche degne di questo nome e
quindi non abbiamo un accesso
generalizzato che superi una percentuale
accettabile a delle reti molto veloci a
delle reti a banda larga a delle reti di
alta capacità se non bastasse questo
terribile handicap un ritardo
inaccettabile per un paese come il
nostro nel 2020
non abbiamo una sufficiente diffusione
dei device la stessa istat è intervenuta
circa un mese fa denunciando il fatto
che moltissime famiglie italiane
probabilmente la maggioranza e non solo
il meridione come è stato detto non
dispongono di almeno un pc in famiglia
voi capite che cosa questo ha
significato innanzitutto per i bambini
ei ragazzi che non avevano proprio lo
strumento per poter accedere alla
didattica online ma voi capite anche che
questo è il segno di quanto poco fosse
penetrata nella mentalità del popolo
italiano nel suo complesso parliamo
dell'intero popolo italiano che è stato
messo in lockdown l'importanza la
centralità di questo modo di comunicare
noi sappiamo poi che questo non è solo
un modo di comunicare ma è una nuova
tecnologia che cambia profondamente le
modalità i linguaggi e anche i contenuti
della comunicazione quindi in ritardo è
un ritardo clamorosamente culturale e di
mentalità non soltanto ed è già
gravissimo un ritardo di tipo
tecnologico un ritardo di tipo
infrastrutturale ecco quindi che una
prima riflessione che dobbiamo fare è
questa che se dopo una grande crisi come
sempre stato nella storia
l'unico modo per rimontare le terribili
conseguenze di carattere antropologico
psicologico ma soprattutto sociologico
ed economico e occupazionale è quello di
fare grandi investimenti pubblici e in
questo caso ci si sta già attrezzando
sia livello nazionale che a livello
europeo con dei piani veramente notevoli
le bisogna assolutamente scegliere gli
investimenti nelle infrastrutture
digitali come investimenti centrali
se si vuole in qualche modo riuscire da
questa terribile situazione migliori più
strutturati più avanzati più innovativi
più moderni rispetto a come ci siamo
entrati
l'altro piano di investimenti detto en
passant non può che essere quello per lo
sviluppo sostenibile per un'economia
rispettosa dell'ambiente in competizione
con i cambiamenti climatici
ma di queste due cose ancora non si
sente parlare non si sente parlare del
fatto che la maggior parte delle risorse
deve essere indirizzata a queste due
scelte di fondo che proprio perché
infrastrutturali garantiscono poi la
dimensione strutturale nuova e diversa
per un'italia che si ricostruisce dopo
quello che è avvenuto
ma ci sono altre riflessioni da fare
rispetto all'esperienza che si è appena
sedimentata in tutta italia e cioè che
l'accesso per quanto fortunoso e per
quanto difficoltoso e per quanto di
cattiva qualità al web da parte di tutti
gli italiani e per molti per la prima
volta ha creato una definitiva
moltiplicazione anzi frammentazione anzi
dispersione dei canali di informazione e
di comunicazione
consideriamo che oggi abbiamo una
disponibilità di punti di partenza di
informazioni e opinioni e altrettanti
punti di ricevimento
che costituiscono una vera e propria
nuova torre di babele
non lo dico perché sto invocando come
dire una concentrazione che sarà il
mercato come sempre poi ad operare come
è successo in passato con le televisioni
e con le radio e con i giornali lo dico
perché questa enorme dispersione di
solito porta con sé una bassa qualità
del prodotto e soprattutto una
insufficiente massa critica di risorse
finanziarie per produrre qualche cosa
che possa reggere il confronto del
mercato interno ma soprattutto del
mercato internazionale
parlo quindi di prodotti di
comunicazione informazione ma anche il
rischio di perdere nuovi contributi
nuovi linguaggi nuovi protagonisti
proprio perché c'è una sorta di eccesso
di offerta
molti sono preoccupati perché questa
informazione comunicazione dispersa in
mille rivoli e anche alla base delle
cosiddette fake news le false notizie
è vero ed è vero che le false notizie
sono un problema sono un problema dal
punto di vista dell'opinione pubblica
dal punto di vista politico dal punto di
vista
della cyber security dal punto di vista
del terrorismo informatico dal punto di
vista soprattutto visto quello di cui ci
siamo dovuti occupare in questi mesi
della salute pubblica troppe
informazioni non validate
scientificamente passate al di là al di
sopra o al di sotto delle fonti
ufficiali hanno diffuso informazioni che
come minimo hanno fatto perdere tempo
come massimo hanno anche creato
grandissimi danni e grandissimi problemi
dal punto di vista proprio della
integrità di persone che hanno rischiato
di fare scelte sbagliate dal punto di
vista della prevenzione e della terapia
del covip così come di altre patologie
qual è la soluzione dal mio punto di
vista non è preventiva perché ha un
atteggiamento censorio di non si sa chi
perché non si sa chi dovrebbe gestire un
atteggiamento censorio
io preferisco un assetto anarchico ma mi
rendo ben conto che il problema c'è e il
problema esiste allora io credo che
quando andremo a una concentrazione
delle fonti e degli snodi del web
noi avremo anche la possibilità di
controbattere alle centrali della
disinformazione
voi sapete che questo tema è all'ordine
del giorno a causa del recente scontro
violentissimo e pubblico tra twitter e
il presidente trump quindi a quei
livelli diciamo che siamo già al momento
della verità al redde razione ultimo
discorso va fatto perché l'informazione
la comunicazione ai siti è il mondo
delle nuove generazioni e le nuove
generazioni in italia sono sempre state
tenute a margine
ricordiamo che prima della pandemia noi
avevamo 100mila giovani che all'anno
lasciavano il paese per fare i lavori
più diversi da quelli più umili a quelli
più sofisticati oppure i medici tant'è
vero che ci sono mancati eco teniamo
conto che se noi pensiamo di far
ripartire il paese senza il
coinvolgimento delle nuove generazioni
non solo attraverso la loro voce
i loro contenuti loro bisogni e le loro
aspettative ma anche attraverso la
comprensione e la facilitazione dei loro
strumenti di comunicazione che non sono
quelli degli adulti è sostanzialmente
soltanto il digitale
noi non riusciamo a riscrivere un
cammino condiviso anche
generazionalmente del nostro paese
bene vi ringrazio